from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between starbucks in japan and the us
this is food wars
in japan our hot coffee comes in four
sizes
short
short
tall
tall
grande
the grande
and venti
and of course live
[Music]
starbucks episode i'm taking a sip of
everything in japan our iced coffee
comes in four sizes
short so we start with the tall
too good and
grande grande
and benti now when we get to the ice
venti size it gets a little bit
different so our ice venti ain't 20 it's
24 ounces and then we have a bigger size
the trenta
which is 30 fluid ounces for your iced
coffee aficionados who also hate your
bladder this is the one for you so in
japan we have this handy coffee traveler
it's 12 cups of coffee so you just take
this off and set the cup right here
i'm disappointed because our coffee
traveler box is this
it's 96 fluid ounces
so this peels off which is nice
this is funner than ours
i like that one look this is like
[Music]
we got this boring box look at this
ugh
it's like a caveman
[Music]
so here is everything you can only find
on the menu at starbucks in japan
and here is everything you can get at a
u.s starbucks you cannot get in japan
holy
a bit of clarification we know that
starbucks will customize drink orders
and there's thousands of variations of
special secret menu items plus now
thanks to tick-tock there are endless
new drinks so these are things on the
official starbucks menu in japan and the
us so japan starbucks update their menu
very often so by the time this video is
released they might not be available
sorry
this one is called
gold peach frappuccino
[Music]
i really love peach and this is good 7
out of ten
noise
gold pineapple frappuccino pink frozen
lemonade and passion tea
it's a little bit sour use citrus and
tea
it's the worst
what happened to you
one out of ten
hojicha classic latte so hojicha is
roasted japanese green tea that
originated in kyoto 100 years ago
this is good
fantastic i'll give this
nine out of ten chai chocolate
frappuccino
what
too sweet
espresso affogato so affogato is the
process of pouring espresso shot onto
ice cream
i don't know about you
again it's too sweet
we've got
dark mocha chip cream
i'm so sorry i spilt most of it the last
one we've got
mango passion tea
and as you can imagine this has strong
mango taste
i feel like i'm hitting a wall here guys
and you know what would help that
the us does not have as many exclusives
as they do in japan at least not as
frequently but at the time of shooting
this it is the fall you know that means
starbucks usa fans pumpkin spice latte
every fall
the entire country
loses their mind and they go buy
pumpkins and they get themselves this
which is pretty much a latte that tastes
like pumpkin pie
as basic as it is it is pretty good
starbucks has decided to introduce a new
fall beverage to their lineup and that
is this the apple crisp macchiato let's
check it out
[Music]
what is this oh man that's terrible
what's wrong with you guys you thought
this can compete with the pumpkin spice
latte not at all does it sound like i'm
like losing my mind because i'm like
really keyed up right now
i'm gonna do my best to pretend like i'm
not unhinged starbucks in the u.s is
this
moving on flat white
what is a flat white this is a flat
white
frappuccinos
strawberry funnel cake frappuccino
that is really sweet
on a scale of one to ten that gets like
ten joes
jozio's that's how i'm writing them i
cannot imagine any time of the day
wanting that but wtmoc what is that
eight years
chai
cream oh god come on the caramel ribbon
crunch
yeah it's still really bad
java chip frappuccino
nope
last one thank you god double
chocolatey chip
cream frappuccino
[Music]
that's not nearly as chocolatey as the
other one there's like less chocolate
and there's double on the title and we
also got
limited tea this one is called youth
berry
so youth berry is citrus white tea
featuring mango pineapple and acai
wow so should be healthy and next one
we have roasted green tea we drink this
on a daily basis with breakfast
lunch dinner
anytime you want
it's our go drink also in the u.s you
can get iced black teas can't get those
in japan i don't know why you can get
these varieties an iced royal english
breakfast tea latte tea
sucks so i have very low expectations
for this
expectations met the next one you have
here is an ice london fog tea i don't
know it makes it foggy
i don't know and you can also get an
iced matcha lemonade other ice black
teas i cannot get my hands on is the
iced guava black tea and iced peach
green tea well i bet that peach one's
pretty good cold brews and nitro cold
brews you can get yourself a nitro cold
brew right here
and also a salted caramel cream cold
brew
vanilla sweet cream cold brew when i say
i was taking a sip of everyone i'm
taking a sip everyone i'm like
caffeine drunk
i bet that was good four hours ago you
get yourself an iced
shaken espresso is that what this is
does it sound like i'm like losing my
mind
[Music]
all right the honey almond milk flat
white
it's so terrible it tastes plasticky
so here is starbucks origami starbucks
origami is one cup drip coffee system so
it's got six origamis
and this is what it looks like
you unfold it
like this
so you just put this over a cup
and let's add some hot water
easy peasy japanese
and starbucks coffee is served
refreshers
refreshers
what are refreshes you ask i'm not quite
sure they look like juice oh it's like
stuff floating in these fruit and stuff
kiwi starfish no star fruit
that'd be worth their starfish in this
these were a good idea good call
starbucks ooh mango dragon fruits here
we go
blended strawberry lemonade
very good and this is the strawberry
side lemonade refresher
not as good iced pineapple matcha i
don't want this at all do it
so here is all the food you can only get
at starbucks in japan
so many here's exclusive food you can
get in the u.s you can't get in japan
breakfast sandwiches i'm going in turkey
bacon sandwich double smoked bacon
cheddar and egg i think yes impossible
breakfast sandwich sausage egg and
cheese
classic
spinach feta wrap
oh yeah
this is the bacon gouda
sandwich you get yourself an avocado
spread
these little guys are egg bites bacon
and greer egg white roasted red pepper
also these that i bet are not any good
the kale and portobello mushroom egg
bites no thanks now moving on to bagels
so what they were able to give me was
cinnamon raisin plain bagel
you can also get cheese onion and garlic
bagels everything bagels and sprouted
grain bagels and of course they come
with a cream cheese spread so i've got
this
shrimp avocado salad wrap
corn side chicken salad
so it's a root vegetable chicken salad
wrap
on the onion
pepper pan and onion
we've got caesar chicken focaccia
grilled vegetable and soy beans hambagu
hambagu is like hamburger beef patty
nice combination i didn't expect that so
let's go to the next one egg sandwiches
pork patty and english muffin egg and
ham sandwich
[Music]
sandwich it's got chicken tomato sauce
smells nice
and next one
big sausage
we got the crispy grilled cheese should
i even open it it's just grilled cheese
right bread and cheese you get it
the tomato
mozzarella panini
turkey pesto sandwich
are we gl are we happy i did that ham
and swiss panini oh the chicken caprese
panini yeah now we're talking
yeah that's right got the italian flag
in one sandwich right there uh this one
is the chicken bacon panini let's open
it up
you can also get yourself protein boxes
there's a bunch of them the one i wanted
didn't have any you can also get a
chicken and quinoa protein bowl
so here we've got baked goods all right
so let's start with this one it's a
biscuit
we've got this waffle which
really looks great this cute
strawberry cake pump
it's just like art
red bean paste and
butter a red bean is really popular in
japan i know it's kind of strange but
when you come to japan
please try this alright next one we've
got this matcha
cake which looks very beautiful
it makes me wanna post this on instagram
lemon cake also looks great this
chocolate scone
and
tea scone
are you going to put hari's face on this
hello harry
and next one we've got
baked cheese tart this is so cute look
how small it is cake pops yeah their
cake pops are big eyes are tiny double
chocolate brownie chocolate chip cookie
and although they're pretty popular they
were out when we went in you get
yourself a marshmallow dream bar
croissants
croissants almond croissant
butter croissant
here we go
chocolate croissant
ham swiss croissant loaves and cakes
banana nut loaf this is the pumpkin loaf
cinnamon coffee cake
soybean the iced lemon loaf
cheese danish blueberry muffin
and of course blueberry scone can we get
harry's face on that
so here we've got packaged foods so this
one is avocado cream cheese tortilla
chips
i will definitely get this with beer no
coffee i need a beer
let's go to the next one in japanese we
say
but this is german right
[Music]
but i'm curious
this matcha bam kuhn
it has really strong much flavor i love
this wow
thank you for coming into my life
chocolate and nuts for timber
and this one is cheese
and fruits protein bar if you take a
bite
you're gonna be
so we've got this
yogurt and banana granola this one right
here is
berry yogurt and berry granola
[Music]
what we got here they got their barbecue
chips
hippies organic chickpeas
popcorn
yes
organic fruit puree just eat the fruit
that grow on the tree i put in plastic
first almonds
ooh chocolate covered espresso beans
biscottis
madelines and
sweet potato chips that wasn't enough
you can also get pre-packaged shortbread
cookies dark chocolate grams rip van
waffles and justin's dark chocolate
peanut butter cups sorry justin they
weren't there
so here we've got this dessert section
it all looks great right let's start
with this oreo cookie cake
cinnamon bun
chocolate donut oreo cookie doughnut
with this white chocolate
glazed donut
it's so sticky we've got this jeremy
soup
peach tart and this one is
lemon tart we've got this banana cake
and next one cheesecake
all right so last one they've got
strawberry tart which looks very great
but i don't have sweet tooth so i'm
going to give all of these to my friends
in japan a venti latte with non-fat milk
is 205 calories 0.6 grams of fat
30.2 grams of carbs 20.6 grams of
protein 280 milligrams of sodium and
225 milligrams of caffeine
in the u.s the same venti cafe latte
contains 170 calories 0.4 grams of fat
25 grams of carbs 16 grams of protein
190 milligrams of sodium and 115
milligrams of that sweet sweet caffeine
our venti mocha has
541 calories
too much our venti mocha has 450
calories ah yes
venti milka
adult hot chocolate this is a venti
caramel frappuccino in japan ours has
487 calories it looks really bad so
i'm going to put
whipped cream
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey george your whipped creams look a
little wimpy there buddy gotta do how we
do in the usa check this out
boom
take that environment in the u.s ours
has less calories only 470.
i brought reusable straws
i don't get it this is so bad
what about the cost this venti
frappuccino is 627 yen or
5.69 cents us
can you put the price down please in the
us the caramel frappuccino is
5.45 which is around 600 japanese yen
it's kind of close but you must consider
that the us venti is four fluid ounces
bigger so let's do that math
looks like it's a bit cheaper in the u.s
so
here is my favorite frappuccino
this is called
matcha frappuccino do you have this in
the u.s
yes george we do in fact have the matcha
frappuccino here in the us too i don't
recall putting that in the script so
i think you pulled a fast one and got us
to buy you a frappuccino so
enjoy
it
this is delicious
excellent
[Music]
japan starbucks
doesn't disclose their ingredients so we
emailed their customer support
but as of today they haven't gotten back
to us what are you doing in starbucks
you know i just respond to george
so here is what we do know our
cappuccino is made of espresso steamed
milk and foam milk
in the u.s our cappuccino is made up of
milk and brut espresso not a lot of info
in this section going on something
that's not a lot we don't appreciate
being left unread starbucks our caramel
frappuccino is made of blended eyes with
milk whipped cream
real caramel and espresso
i taste the way perfume smells you know
in the u.s our caramel frappuccino is
made up of ice milk carrageenan
vanilla syrup coffee obviously and the
caramel syrup is made up of sugar water
natural flavor citric acid
potassium potassium sorbet salt mino
diglycerides soy lecithin and sulfates a
japanese caramel macchiato contains
vanilla syrup milk espresso and original
caramel sauce and ours in the u.s
contains milk brute espresso vanilla
syrup which is made of sugar water
natural flavors potassium absorbent
citric acid corn syrup butter cream salt
mono diglycerides soy lecithin and
sulfates
hey if you enjoyed watching this episode
of us versus japan we actually have
another series comparing the us and the
uk right here